these guys are pin cushions you're
pricking them all the time they got
Patches all over their body there's data
flowing out of their eyeballs and you're
pouring trackers down their throats and
isotope water like it's insane
several weeks ago we released an
incredibly popular episode featuring
Christian Blumenfeld and Gustav Eden and
despite them earnestly answering every
question I asked I was still left
wondering how did they do it what
exactly is going on in Norway to produce
such towering figures in the world of
Swim Bike Run well here today with
answers is the coach of the Norwegian
train himself olav Alexander boo we have
got a lot of attention of how we have
implemented sensors instruments
technology science
but one thing that maybe doesn't get so
much attention is also the human aspect
of it olav is a sports scientist and
Elite coach who helped to devise a
protocol of testing grounded in the
scientific method that is achieving
undisputable real world results in the
form of Olympic medals and Triathlon
World Championship victories in the same
way that I expect the best from
Christian and Gustav I can't expect this
for myself in today's highly anticipated
conversation we cover Olaf's background
the specific protocols that he has
instituted that have garnered so much
success understanding how we can work on
different things to to excel performance
is fundamental laws of energy in
training and so much more you can always
come there with as much details as much
data you really want to but if people
don't buy into it if they don't trust
you if they don't feel like it nothing's
gonna work exactly
so here we go the Norwegian train rides
again in this conversation between me
and Olaf Alexander
[Music]
olavitz finally a pleasure to meet you
in person thank you for doing this uh
we're recording this on the heels of
having sat down with uh Christian Gustav
and now we're going to dive deep into
the science what's really happening in
Bergen what is this Norwegian equation
that you have unlocked that is rewriting
the record books in in Triathlon
um
so much to talk to you about today but I
guess the first thing just to open it up
is like how did you make these guys so
good this is what everyone wants to know
I think there is uh or we are actually
on our past towards an easier answer but
unfortunately it's not an easy answer
just yet because
I think on the one side of course what
we have got a lot of attention of uh
over the last years is how we have
implemented sensors instruments
technology science
but one thing that maybe doesn't get so
much attention is also that there is a
big portion of it or maybe still the
majority of the portion of it still is
also the human aspect of it
and we are still uh we will that's how
it's going to be coaching will still be
for many years uh and decades maybe even
uh big Parts uh just human interaction
but of course what Science and
Technology helps us to do is to start to
become more aware of things that really
matters for each individual right so you
you're known as the data guy you've got
an engineering background you don't have
a background in Triathlon uh you kind of
entered the world of Endurance Sports
with a bit of a beginner's mind but with
this kind of understanding of how data
sets could be powerful and up leveling
what we understand about human
physiology and performance and we're
going to get into all of those
techniques because they're so
fascinating but to kind of
um Echo what you just mentioned
amidst this conversation about what
you're doing with these athletes and how
that's differentiating
um their performances from the rest of
the pack what kind of gets missed or is
underappreciated is the importance of
the human element and you know what I
would call culture right your your
working very intensely with a small
group of athletes and
none of the data sets are going to make
any difference if these guys don't get
along if their mindset isn't right if
they aren't on the same page and
receptive to what you're trying to teach
so let's start with the culture piece
yeah
um
I think the very fundament of everything
is culture
um and exactly that I'm also very
fortunate because
I've had uh I've been in a
place where I met a lot of good people
that also took me on a journey
and brought me where I am today as well
and allowed me to develop
um both as a human but also into the
sports of Triton for example actually
I'm not that the funny thing is I'm not
that interested in sports itself that's
not really my passion my passion is more
actually humans or they say what I
dubbed today Peak finding Peak Human
Performance I think that could be in in
many different places but culture
um if you don't have the culture the
habits the the work ethics and I think
also
uh the passion for each other uh then
you can always come there with as much
details as much data you really want to
but if people don't buy into it if they
don't trust you if they don't feel like
it
then
nothing's gonna work exactly yeah so so
that's that's the that is for me they're
very fundament and also one of the
things that maybe I I don't communicate
too much about it externally but one
thing that always is my biggest worry
especially when you have two such
extreme athletes like Christian and
Gustav
that on the one side there are in a
unique position where they are able to
train against each other with each other
uh in in in in every day and they know
their strengths and weaknesses
but that means also when they come to
the competition they know also mm-hmm
water right who they have to win over
and I think that that is a stronger
position than going to competition and
don't know who you are going to compete
against yeah so for me that day I have
that we together they together have a
really good relationship is uh
maybe one of the things that plays the
most with my emotions too
it's uh it's no small feat I mean just
having spent a couple hours with them
um obviously things didn't go
Christian's way in in Kona and Gustav
finally got you know what he's been
searching for all along uh Christian
historically you know the person who has
been a little bit more successful and
had more of the Limelight on him and you
can't help but think like I was
wondering like are these guys still
going to be friends like how does this
work like how are they going to move
forward as training Partners as
roommates
Etc to people who spend all their time
together and the tone and the tenor is
set by the culture that you're trying to
create for this small intimate group of
athletes who are really trying to do
things that no human being has ever done
like inevitably you would think there's
going to be a culture Clash like there
can only be one alpha like how is this
going to play out and to see their
affection for each other and and to
really understand like oh they're their
bond is deeper than race results
that doesn't come easy and that is you
know unusual yeah
um I think
of course there are many ways to to
manage this or as a group or where we
have different roles but one thing that
I try to guide this a little bit from
the sideline or let's say a little bit
more not so visible I have of course the
talks we have actually quite a lot of
discussions or not I wouldn't say
discussions but more conversations
around
um values values in life what really
matters who do we want to be uh
um and and that's that also boils down
very much to uh to priorities where do
you actually decide to spend your your
thoughts throughout the day weeks and so
on and that's also very much affected by
what kind of people do we surround
ourselves with and for me it's very
important that we always surround us you
can always find fascinating people that
have done extreme things and other
things but maybe their values doesn't
necessarily
align with or values it doesn't mean
that their values are wrong but it's not
it's not it doesn't align necessarily
with or values and for me the most
important thing is that is to be a good
human it's a good human nothing is worth
anything unless think of it this way and
that is that if you win a gold medal and
this gold medal or that competition
you're competing in has no value to
anybody else that gold medals only have
no value at all the reason for why
something has a value is because the
society around us really evaluate
and that's why also it's so important
for me that on one side we are
individuals but on the other side too we
we only really have a value
if we have a value for this for the
society around us yeah so so that means
also that when we choose who we surround
us with it it's important that we always
surround us with people
that have values that are maturing uh
nurturing or not necessarily consciously
but it's more like your being in an
atmosphere yet where you pick up
consciously and subconsciously things
that uh contributes to to Bringing or
making a better human and that means
like also to to the question of Alphas
uh and that is that we don't spend very
much time on focusing on who is the
alpha or not we can joke about it I
think the last time we made a joke about
that must have been probably a year ago
one and a half year ago because I think
that in a group if you have a lot of
attention to who is the alpha and or
this discussion about Alpha let's say
being a leader and these kind of things
there will always be a fight for this
there will always be a rivalry for this
but
this is not really what is important
what is really important for me is or
more let's say each of our own
development and as long as we always
progress
and we take care of the people around us
we eventually will achieve our goals so
how does that
translate into tactics strategies and
and practices like I'm thinking about
the applicability of these principles to
the coach that's listening to the CEO or
the executive anybody who has to lead
and Empower teams of people how does it
play out on a daily basis in terms of
you know curating that type of culture I
think habits takes time to develop but
to maintain a habit as long as you make
sure that then it's much easier to
maintain a maintain a habit but
developing habits that's very often the
thing that
costs energy to do uh and that means
that normally in the daily life of our
training and so on I don't have to spend
too much time on let's say on culture
and these kind of things because I I'm
very well aware
and spending quite a lot of time on also
evaluating not necessarily the things
they say but also the things they don't
say and communicate
um and when I see that there are things
that are starting to worry me a little
bit uh I I'm not afraid of taking taking
up that topic even though it might be
unpleasant but I think it's much better
to ask the question because they also
know my intention so even if it's an
unpleasant question but they know that
my intention is good
then I think it and there's trust yeah
yeah exactly exactly so so and that
means that in in the daily life when we
are doing the training uh and so on it's
uh we we have a very open dialogue about
strategy about tactics and all these
kind of things of course that know each
other quite well um it was quite funny a
little bit leading into the competition
or in Kona we we did a lot last
preparation weeks and then
um
of course they are
[Music]
having a little bit of like let's call
it serious fun
leading because they are feeling each
other out a little bit on their in in
the training
and of course they talk a little bit
more like open-minded a little bit about
how they feel and so on but eventually
the last day
I know
what of course Christian is thinking
that okay this is my strength this is
how I'm going to leverage it and also
the funny thing was that Gustav also
told me that
when I get out of energy lab
this is where I'm going to make my
search so I knew already but of course
that last part of it I can't say to
Christian because Gustavo of course
comes and tells it to me in in
confidence in confidence in the same way
that the Christian does but that's fine
when you have this small last thing and
you say okay this is what I'm I'm gonna
put together that's fine to keep the
small part there but keep it being open
being transparent and actually also
actually being willing to expose
yourself I think is also very important
because when we find our competitive
advantages
um it's very easy to grow into that this
is my thing but eventually people will
catch up
but if you are willing actually to
expose that competitive Advantage share
it maybe with your strongest rival it
also puts you in in a place where you
know that you're building your rival
stronger but it also put yourself in an
uncomfortable position also where you
need to start a hunt also for new
competitive advantages and this way we
also drive not only let's say the the
physiological part but also the
psychological part and build it build
each other stronger uh also in in in
training yeah it's delicate though like
it feels fragile right if you get one of
those pieces just a little bit wrong the
whole thing could collapse on top of it
itself
that's also where I think it is
important to create robustness too I
think that if if that had been a worry
with for me that it starts to become
very fragile
then I would sit down and actually spend
quite a lot more time talking about this
kind of top-based culture and these kind
of things because I knew that now things
are fragile and the chances for that
suddenly something breaks and either
require even more
energy to bring it back again and you
can't really focus on the details or
let's say those small marginal gains you
actually back just the basic building
try and repair things that's that's a
situation that I think I I or I know at
least for myself would be very hard to
to live with so in those situations when
I start a few things are fragile those
are the things those are the times where
data and everything else really doesn't
matter anything for me anymore the only
thing that matters for me now is the the
relationship and bringing that
robustness right so that you have some
room to play in Kona the way that the
race played out
did that meet expectations did it defy
expectations did it surprise you and
what are you kind of taking away from
that experience to go back to the lab
and learn more
I think the biggest mistake we did uh
going into the competition uh is that we
we knew that there were Outsiders
that were going to take risks but we
just delayed lows Etc which was uh based
on everybody's feedback Christian Gustav
having trained together with him
um that no
they could let him go
but there were others where there were
more cautious about and then they get to
pay for it on the Run afterwards so but
in times of but in terms of uh
performance uh
I they were Gustav was one minute of
what we predicted would be the final
time for the rest one minute off and
that was the swim
was uh
what we expected to be the bike was
where it expected to be the Run was a
little bit more than a minute slower
than what we would expect it to be so I
would say that performance wise what we
prepare for
it was where we where we
expected to be but we
we just miscalculated a little bit uh
let's say or competitive and I I
actually I don't spend very much time on
competitor analysis and so on because I
know the Christian Gustav really have a
better feeling and a bad understanding
of that than me so I I trust them much
more uh
to to do that part my goal is rather to
just make sure that we prepare how we
think is possible to prepare for race
with the given conditions that we have
we went from a Sprint distance in Bergen
which is on the opposite side of the
spectrum we knew we had very little time
to prepare uh going into Kona and yeah
that making sure that that part fits
together is is the most important for me
and then the rest is safe right yeah who
could have predicted that Sam lay low
would do what he did that that can't be
part of how you're preparing for a race
anyway
um but with respect to Christian and his
performance
um
you know obviously things didn't go the
way that he would have liked them to
have gone what was that conversation
with him like after the race
um actually we really haven't had that
because I normally like it's I know that
Christian is spending quite a lot of
time evaluating his own performance also
after the rest and you're you you don't
necessarily because one part is the data
or the other part is also the other
things that you can't collect with data
especially in a race where you can't use
equally much instruments as you are
doing in training so the qualitative
part of the analysis after a race like
this often takes a little bit of time
and it needs maybe a little bit time to
mature and as as I know uh Christian
also said earlier today and that is that
it's still something that they playing
or playing around
or let's say rewinding in his mind a
little bit what could he have done
different what didn't go according to
plan uh
and of course now over the next days we
we are starting to discuss it a little
bit but it's not like throughout one
conversation we will have the answer to
it it's something that will we are
starting we will start to get a picture
of it then we get more the course
picture and then as we start to work
you'll still start to rewind or play off
the scenarios in your head and that will
eventually
come out through into the into the
program so
leaving corner
heading back also now long distance
Triathlon is not our main focus anymore
or not or focus at all and now the
challenge that we are really focusing on
is the Olympics so for me actually
uh the only thing that I'm thinking of
now is basically how do we how can we
Bermuda unfortunately I don't have uh
it's very difficult to do very much with
because we come from Kona they have to
recover an offer a couple and bring
bring it back into training then they
get Saint George uh half rmn uh World
Champs and then a week after you get
Bermuda the problem with going to
Bermuda that race is that you have so
much noise in the training with both
that you have been doing races that are
very different from what you are gonna
do in Bermuda you have a lot of travel
uh and other things that that is
happening there that
in Bermuda you don't we can't say that
okay this is what we did this is okay
this is how it turned out in Bermuda if
I would do that I would probably end up
with a lot of false positives
um no it's very unusual it doesn't
create a clean data set from which to
extract any kind of truths yeah yeah
exactly and that that means that it's
actually from Bermuda into Abu Dhabi
where we get I think it's three or four
weeks
where we really can start to do some
work and in Abu Dhabi then we would have
our
an ID okay this is what it looked like
in training this is what a data sex look
like this is the feedback I had from the
at least and discussions and then this
is the Russell Abu Dhabi then you get
the Benchmark against others and this
will be the point where we also go back
into the labs and and start to do more
uh structured uh Olympic targeted work
to eventually or hopefully be able to do
something that nobody have done before
and that is to go from the Olympic to
the Iron Man and backpack
yeah no right yeah
uh they're so different and I want to
get into
um you know how all of this unfolded and
then
um your unique approach to uh the
relationship between science data and
Human Performance and I think the best
way to do that is just to do it
chronologically like
to recount your entrance into the
Norwegian Triathlon equation and kind of
go from there because you've been
learning as you as you've been going and
you did come in with
you know this engineering background but
this beginner's mind without all the
kind of calcified baggage around what
you're supposed to do and the way we've
always done it and this is the way it
works and no we can't try that kind of
mindset
yeah
um I I as long as I can remember and
both my my my grandparents but also my
parents have said that I had a
big hunger or uh thirst or curiosity to
understand things since I was a kid
um
to the point where my parents had just
had to clean almost the house for
everything that could be
tinkered with Tinker with you are you
the guy who's like taking the TV apart
and stuff yes
and and and when I first had done that
and I looked into it and saw how things
were I was not so Keen to put it back
together again right A lot of times
lying around the house so that was not
the fun but that was not so fun uh
but yeah technology
it's also a little bit of a paradox on
one side I really love nature and one of
the times where where I actually
um are able to recharge the most is
actually when I'm completely away from
technology we're now I'm out in nature
I'm not able to be reached um places
where there is no uh phone connection or
other things like this it takes a few
days and this is when I really start to
find my own piece and this is one of the
things that also I very often miss the
most uh but on other side also
technology and how we can learn more
about Humanity about what we do uh just
advance or let's say be be able to
advance faster in what we do there I
think technology is really powerful and
uh the way I actually got into I started
some businesses uh that I built up and
sold and then in 2011 we it was a
we had a family accident uh I lost uh uh
four family members in a helicopter
crash uh we were going we were building
a mountain diary Farm
and uh which we was more for for the
family so I flew first off with parts of
my family and then the helicopter turned
back uh home and it came came back up
with the rest of the family and it
crashed uh and um there was nothing we
could do uh
uh so and there it it is a remote area
where there is no phone reception so I
had to run for one hour uh to get up on
a Mountaintop how old were you
um at that time I think that was my 30th
birthday it was oh my 30th birthday was
gonna be celebrated when we were up
there at the mountain dive oh my Lord so
um uh I remembered running up the
mountain there uh I got some time to
think and I thought okay I I really have
to do some because I came from a more
much more explosive background
where I really like I really liked power
training and I sailing was sailing yeah
and that's also one thing that people
don't think too much about but in a
sailing or in very competitive
environment everything there's nothing
happening about everything is just five
second burst yeah like super explosive
and every second counts because if
you're losing one second throughout the
attack before you are able to get up to
speed again that's already quite a lot
of meters and for every attack you're
making or every job you're making now
and you're losing time that's you can't
do that if you really want to be the
best
so from there of course it went into
Endurance Sports I did a lot of
experimentation but again I was with
business I found a very good Mentor and
that was he was the CFO of
pricewaterhousecoopers in Norway and he
took me under his wings and and and
guided me uh in sports when I decided I
need to do something with my uh Fitness
uh
I just started to
Google who who really is the the person
to ask for and there because for your
own Fitness yeah for my own pursuit of
being an athlete exactly yeah to do
something with it because I obviously
needed a coach or I thought I needed a
coach to to to to help me advance
and
I found out there was a guy
named oyon Watson or Dr Oyen Watson and
we had a common friend which put me in
contact with him we met both of us were
doing kiting and that became my journey
a very special Journey because in he he
the way that he coached me or inspired
me he was very much not he didn't tell
me okay no this is you have to read this
on page this page or this is working
exactly this way sometimes it could have
could be a little bit more direct in his
guiding but most of the time I would say
probably more than 90 95 percent of the
time uh he was much more in maturing
that
I had to figure out I had to find out
right by by reading discouraging and
empowering yeah ultimately allowing you
to have your own experience yeah and uh
I I that became something that became
such a big passion for me because I
really I'm also extremely competitive in
a way that I want to be the best in the
things I do
so in the same way that I expect of
course the best from Christian and Gusto
the independent of what kind of goal
they are pursuing uh I I can't expect
less for myself I have to expect for
myself to have the same Pursuit
for developing or being a really good
coach uh understanding how we can how we
can work on different things to to excel
performance and that is a never-ending
Pursuit because there are so many things
about physiology that we still don't
know I would say that it's probably more
things we still don't know than what we
do know and that is very that's actually
uh for me uh makes it very interesting
to work on it because it then also
becomes a research project on each
individual uh it's not something and
also that there's so much growth yeah to
be had right I mean this is a big thing
when you come into Triathlon and you're
like yeah you guys have been doing this
but like you don't even really
understand what this means and there's
so many other things we could be doing
yeah and that that I think that I think
when I also have done two athletes that
are very willing to join in on the
research projects too which makes it
much more fun and I think fun is a very
big that's that's super important
actually but
where it makes it interesting you know
exactly you say it is growth and maybe
growth is in the end what it all is
about if you don't have growth anymore
as an athlete or even as a coach I think
you start to
Flatline level yeah yeah
so you're exploring your athlete's side
you're learning about the science of
human performance how does this
ultimately you know land you at the feet
of the fledgling Norwegian Triathlon
Federation or you know program or
whatever it was at the time so it
happened to be that
I had never thought over that there was
a national team in torahman at that time
he was the coach from the Olympic
Federation before the Olympic uh or for
the for the Norwegian Trashman
Federation and for for our
and um it was in 2014 and 50 2014 I
think 15 he then he started to bring me
a little bit more so I I did some
training sessions with them
but eventually he said that you should
really come in and be a part of the
Olympic program in Toronto and start to
use now because he had privately tutored
me in in
in physiology and of course with my
background from technology and I could
start to merge a lot of the studies we
do today there are you you distinguish
between in in Vivo and in vitro and the
problem with in vitro is that you is you
can study things and you can control
things and you can get a result but
you're not able to bring it back into
Human Performance context with the
technology that we have available today
we are getting closer and closer to that
more of the research we are doing can
happen in Vivo or in in the situation
with the athletes and I think this is
something that he as a physiologist uh
also thought was quite inspiring and
interesting to see how quickly I was
able to advance in the understanding of
how performers come to come together and
where he said that Olaf can you help me
with some of the analysis when he was
doing that with the team and as we did
this I think he also found quite a lot
of inspiration in this and that was
eventually where I was sitting down with
Ariel and Aryan and and talking and they
said okay now this was in 2015 leading
into 2016 I started to Shadow RL and
Christian just to see in a lot of
different years from everything from the
bike to basically metabolism and a lot
of other things
what did it what did the training look
like what did the performance look like
more or less trying to understand where
the gaps were
and then us Rio was concluded and we
started up again
a few months later
making or starting to make a way towards
Tokyo
this is when I was asked okay come into
the program and and take over the
scientific part of it and I became part
of the coach team
Julie what would you say to somebody who
comes to you and says you know what I
find your lifestyle or the way that you
eat really aspirational but I'm too busy
I just don't have time I don't want to
be cracking open cookbooks and trying to
learn a new skill when I'm already
exhausted after a long day how do you
guide this person where should they go
the plant power meal planner is really
really such an amazing value it is under
two dollars a week and for that it gives
you this inspiration know-how and
thousands of recipes to create the
plant-based meals that you crave in your
own life so it's so amazing to be able
to log on to the plant power meal
planner and get the recipes the
ingredients the shopping list and then
the support from all of the coaches that
we have available to answer all of your
questions so join us in eating more
healthy vibrant plan plant-based meals
and to kick-start our health intentions
this New Year we're offering you twenty
dollars off a one-year membership with
the code power 20 throughout the entire
month of January to learn more and to
sign up go to
meals.richroll.com again that's promo
code power 20 for 20 off at meals Dot
richroll.com
uh so in Rio you're essentially
observing right and you're kind of
gathering information and data and from
what I understand you you kind of come
to this conclusion looking at Triathlon
like sort of canvassing the landscape
that
despite
extreme advances in the bicycles like
we've seen bikes come a long way uh
beyond that in some kind of aerodynamic
stuff and maybe you know Carbon plated
shoes what have you there really wasn't
that much
advancement in the sport I mean I think
the marathons that Dave Scott and Mark
Allen were running way back in the day
until very recently
we're still kind of the gold standard
and people were struggling to Eclipse
those times
now the record book has been Rewritten
but back in 2016 this was sort of the
case right and you have this realization
like oh there's so much more we could be
doing because technology has advanced so
much and data science and these data
sets could actually create models for
much more efficient training to extract
a higher level of performance from the
will the athlete who's willing to kind
of go all in on this with me
yeah uh
the really nice thing I I or one of the
things that I really value with
Christian and Gustav is actually a lot
of the conversations we have because
they also have a lot of ideas and
perspectives on on the sport and
performance and limitations
and that is how I also see that we are
working together as a team it's not like
I'm like a leader or a coach
dictating what they should do but it's
rather we just have different tasks and
for example one thing that me and
Christian were sitting down discussing
this was uh uh when was this this was I
think it was early this year uh or was
it leading into Cozumel I don't remember
exactly but
then when we started to break down okay
what do we think is possible to do in
the swim in the bike and then in the run
one of the things that we when we
started to analyze uh
performances it's quite interesting to
see that if you take Sprint performance
or Olympic spin distance
uh and you compare them you'll see that
you can basically take the swim and you
can multiply it by two point let's say
for the for the fun of it we just say
2.1 a low let's say 2.0 something so
it's a little bit more than a factor
factor two on the swim is the same on
the bike and the same on the run so the
times are almost on all these different
disciplines almost a double that's
that's it
uh if you go from Olympic distance and
you go to Half Ironman distance you're
almost also seeing exactly the same the
time that you're using on the swim if
you go from 1500 meter to 99 meter is
almost minor the same on the bike is
almost lying there and also the same
thing if you're going to run is almost
line there
if you're not go from half arm and you
go to full distance Iron Man is actually
the same for the swim
and for the bike but not the ramp and
then the question becomes why
is there such a big difference on the
Run Part but not on the bike path and
not on a swimming part
and one of the ways that we started to
view this a little bit is that if you
look at the training that you're doing
throughout the day throughout the week
and so on swimming 750 meters you do
every 20 you never have a swim session
as a short session is less than yeah
probably 2500 meters or so or an even
I would say that very seldom less than
3000 meters most of the times more than
four thousand meters even so that means
that
most of the swimming sessions you have
throughout the week you are actually
covering also arm and distance in your
swimming just broken up into into walls
lower intensity High something something
high intensity and so on but you cover
more or less the volume there
the same also goes uh for the bike for
all distances maybe except for for Iron
Man distance in arm and distance of
course you have a working time that is
more than four hours of course 180
kilometers but you do several times a
month maybe rides that are closer to
four hours and sometimes maybe even a
little bit more than four hours on the
bike of course not at the same intensity
but you still get the volume in there
running
is the place
where you yes in your running you always
cover a Sprint distance of five
kilometers in on a run Olympic distance
10 kilometers around most of the session
you will cover even that way if you
count your cooldown or you warm up your
main set in your cooldown
when you come to the half Ironman
distance this is where you okay you
still cover that distance or close to
the distance maybe once a week or at
least a couple of times a month
but the Ironman distance you don't
mm-hmm
and then when you when we start to
understand this then then the question
becomes why
Okay so
what can we do about this right so
basically you're saying that the Olympic
distance triathlete is is
is approximating Iron Man training for
the most part in a way that has been
under appreciated right there there are
more endurance athletes than we've sort
of respected them to be and are closer
uh you know along that path towards
being an Iron Man athlete then one might
originally have surmised so that's the
original kind of idea except for the Run
Part right and translating the training
into taking that athlete from the
shorter distance to the longer distance
the run is where the opportunity lies
that's for one but of course I also I'm
a big believer in specificity uh meaning
that the body will uh
[Music]
what you'll see is that a lot of the
things we we have a very simple approach
in one side you can we have a very
science driven approach to it but it
very often what we see is that it ends
up being a very basic or simple approach
to a lot of things
if you want to perform in heat it won't
help you if you want to put
racing in Kona going to Antarctica and
doing a preparation I will probably not
be a very good idea uh if we prepare
probably quite well to race in
Antarctica but not in corner so you need
to be in the place where you want to
prepare both from understanding the
cause but also course getting used to
the heat that is there
uh the same thing also goes with with
racing I don't think that I think that
the reason why we could come into arm
and racing and really just make a huge
hit there uh and and being very dominant
is because we saw that there was a big
room of improvement or let's say in
Olympic racing we are closer to what I
call PQ map Performance while in arm and
racing we are further away from it it
can have to do with the competitiveness
of the resources that are spent on it to
understand in the physiology and all
these kind of things being involved
there but
um that's why I think that and I think
that for for a period of time now
because now every now and then you start
to get a new picture of okay what can we
do smarter in our training these are the
times you typically make you jump up one
step in in a staircase but us people are
starting to really uh understand this
and and able to extract the margins from
it that's also where you're starting to
see that the sports or let's say those
distances also become more apart again
so now it's more than okay we are in a
place where we're exploiting our gap
which has not been covered in the longer
distances but as the long distance the
people that really just focus on long
distances they will Bridge up and they
will get a competitive Advantage again
because you training as an Olympic
Athlete prepare you for Olympic distance
training for an Ironman do require a
different specialization and the reason
for that is there are two fundamental
laws I really often like to come back to
when things becomes a little bit too
complicated
for example physiology is easy to if you
if you ask somebody about VO2 max for
example you get so many different
answers what's the single best workout
to train your vehicle to buy someone
said long slow distance some will say
high intensity someone say micro
intervals that there are so many
different answers to this and a
cardiologist will have a say that okay
the heart is the most important thing
you get for other people say no it's the
muscles in mitochondria which is the
most important thing of it the fact is
that when you just look at a simple
graph and you plot VO2 on the y-axis and
you plot power on the on the x-axis
you'll see that if you plot five minute
power increasing five minute power on
the x-axis and you plot VO2 on the
y-axis you'll see there's a perfect
correlation between the two so obviously
increasing your five minute power will
obviously also increase your view to Max
if you don't have a high five five
minute power you can't expect to have a
high view to Max now the question
becomes is that I think that too often
in training we end up diving into
physiology and trying to understand it
from a physio physiological perspective
instead of a requirement perspective
what is really the demand or the
requirement that we need to adapt to and
that's also why I think that you will if
you go out and of course now I'm just
showing us some numbers here I really
don't have evidence for this but it's
more like a feeling based on all the
people that I've been talking to and
that is that uh you'll most often find
probably more excellent coaches that
don't have a physiology degree than
excellent coaches that has of this
holiday degree and the reason for that I
think is because the coach doesn't have
a physiology degree he needs to
understand performance from a practical
perspective what what is really the
demand here how can I really work on
that demand while a physiologist very
often because maybe they have been
taught in a book that the heart is the
main limiter and they they start to
obsess too much about an isolated part
in the body rather seeing the holistic
thing about it
and that's why also the two fundamental
laws that I always end up coming back to
and one is the first law of
thermodynamics is that is you can't
create energy you can't destroy energy
you can only convert them from one form
to another form and that means in the
body it means turning calories into
velocity right and the order is
basically being a stationary action
principle meaning that or the law of
least action and that is basically that
energy will always the nature will
always try to solve a task with the
least possible
energy required so if you're gonna run
10K and you start to become better and
better and better at it the body will
always start to try to figure out how
can I do this with the least possible
energy expanded and that's also where
the specificity also comes in because if
you train for Olympic distance triadon
that has a completely different Demand
with bigger surges it requires a higher
power outputs and these kind of things
while an arm and distance don't have
that gun you're not going to have you
don't need a huge five minute power in
an environment if you're gonna put in
huge five minute power your problem on
one side not gonna have a very ideal
metabolic profile and secondly it's
going to cost you too much energy if you
decide to put in a search like that
so we also know that for example that
the heart is grossly inefficient in I
think that statistically for average
population the heart has an efficiency
of 10 percent
and uh I think yeah and like Gusto said
is that
um
his view to Max he knows now because we
have done quite a lot of research and
that is that his view to Max for for
this Iron Man have come down
and the reason for that again is because
you don't since you don't need a big
view to Max you don't need equally big
heart right and we also know that from
nature it's easier to let's say solve
something with higher frequency than
higher Force higher Force costs more and
it puts bigger strain on what you need
to Dimension from a pure physics
perspective
but that back to the stationary action
principle or the other fundamental law
and that is that the nature always try
to solve things as cheaply as possible
so if you're going to be good on the
Iron Man where the PowerPoint is much
lower than it is for for uh Olympic
distance that is going to need an
adaptation and a part of that adaptation
and because and being able to extract
more and more and more from your
capabilities will also result in
reduction in stroke volume because you
don't have the energy if you spend too
much energy maintaining a big view to
Max a big heart and these kind of things
you're obviously focused on training
something that is not necessary the
discipline that you're trying to exactly
excel at yeah um no that makes perfect
sense there's always going to be
compromises and when you're gonna you
know toggle that lever to you know level
up in in in a longer distance race it's
gonna you know sacrifice that high-end
power that you don't necessarily need
what you need is efficiency and you need
the breadth of that aerobic capacity to
last for that number of hours without
you know tapping out your glycogen
stores and all the rest
um
the sort of uh traditional approach the
conventional wisdom around preparing for
uh an endurance event has always been or
historically has been you go get lactate
tested and you do that traditional
Progressive test where you know watts
are increased and at a specific interval
and you prick with lactate and you take
perceived effort and heart rate Etc and
from that you extract your training
zones and then maybe you revisit two or
three months later and you set the
parameters of your training protocol in
accordance with those zones and along
you know uh in conjunction with like
some kind of periodization
situation right you enter the equation
you look at this and you say okay all
fine and well but you know is this
really the best way to do this like
where can we improve upon this so walk
me through like how you kind of looked
at this particular protocol or perhaps
more broadly how we think about
intensity regulation in training and
also the difference between you know
what what you tell an athlete to do and
what they actually do
so I think of course what we have seen
after the Olympics and uh
Christian Gustav and have been featured
a lot of different places and one of the
things that on one side looks of course
a little bit exotic but also get a lot
of attention because it's suddenly they
have blood running down their shirts and
these kind of things dripping from the
air and we we like to joke about it it's
all about blood tear and sweat but uh
these guys are pin cushions you're
pricking them all the time they got
Patches all over their body there's data
flowing out of their eyeballs and you're
taking fecal samples and pouring you
know trackers down their throats and
isotope water like it's insane yeah I
think I think maybe one of the first an
important thing to cover is of course
that I think that if you my advice would
normally be that uh if you really don't
are gonna spend the time or investing in
understanding the strengths and
weaknesses of lactate what affects the
lactate measurements what both from a
contamination perspective but also from
purely that understanding that when we
are measuring that thing we are
measuring our concentration we don't we
don't measure volume and that's that's
actually that's actually a very
interesting topic that we probably could
cover sometime but right that sounds
like a four-hour lecture that my eyes
would glaze over I don't even know you
know what you just said exactly but no
what I mean by that is that uh when you
measure elected in the blood
you measure a concentration it just
tells you that okay from the sample we
made here this is the concentration of
lactating yeah of millimoles yeah in in
of lactate in that volume of blood that
you measuring the problem is that you
don't know how much
do you have in your body in total so
that's for example since you're
measuring in the blood if you have a
reduction in in plasma volume for
example which easily happens as a
function of dehydration change of
climate going to altitude that's already
going to change the concentration guys
that concentration even though you let's
say that you you aim to find your
maximum lactate steady state which is
like a scientific term for or let's say
maybe the only maybe the only uh term
that maybe science is able to agree over
as a as a threshold value is the maximum
like the steady state if you look up
anaerobic threshold and you look for a
different definition you'll probably
find 30 40 50 different definitions of
this and if you go even into the
protocols for how this you'll find even
further ways to do this and you start to
understand of course the weakness and
strength of it maximize the steady state
is a is a it's a construct where you're
just looking at okay what is the highest
sustainable workout you can do uh or
intensity you can do while the lack this
still remains stable right and I have a
question about that that's always
confused me about this because I know
that that's sort of established wisdom
but what it doesn't account for to my
mind and hopefully you can clear this up
is the difference between the athlete
who can maintain that steady state
for I don't know two hours three hours
four hours and the athlete who can
maintain that steady state for 12 hours
or nine hours those are two entirely
different individuals who might have
that same
data set that's going to match up
it doesn't account for that difference
and obviously when you're taking an
athlete from Olympic distance to Ironman
distance that's the determining Factor
I think you pinpointed something that a
lot of people are forgetting and that is
that when you go into the lab and you do
a protocol
or when you look at the power number of
U2 Max number and so on is that you're
actually looking at a just power not
capacity mu to Max is not capacity it's
a power number it's just the equivalent
of let's say that if you said it okay
I can go I'm riding now at 300 watts
it's like you say how how long can you
do that because that's for some yeah for
four days yes or can you do that for
another minute yeah yeah
um and that you could also have measured
that just by view too saying that I'm
writing now the VO2 which is this
because you can have for example just to
give a very simple example and that is
that you can take two athletes that has
80 milliliter per minute per kilogram in
oxygen uptake one can hold that for
three minutes another one can hold that
for six minutes obviously there's a huge
difference there right and it's you
can't explain it by view to Max
and that is capacity the problem with
capacity that is extremely intrusive
invasive to measure capacity and the
easiest way to do it is that you just
need to go out and you need to do you
have to let's say you go
no actually the problem also with biopsy
and this is also one of the places where
unfortunately we see that more and more
that we can't rely on many of the
studies that have done or been done on
muscle biopsies there was a new study
just released now
where they had been looking at muscle
biopsy in general and they actually had
done muscle biopsies I think 12 spots on
just the thigh and they saw that the
distribution of must always say cells or
or muscle fibers are very different
across those locations so suddenly what
it depends on where the biopsy is being
done and and what are they looking for
are they looking for mitochondrial
density or what is the it depends it
depends very much on what you are
looking for because you can take cell
samples and look at for example
mitochondrial respiration uh you can
look at fiber type distribution uh how
much are white
red
cells in the samples for example the
distribution between them but again the
problem with also muscle biopsy is that
there's a concentration measurement and
not the volumetric meaning basically
that you can have two athletes where it
seems like for example one athlete let's
say you take one athlete two Sprinter
athletes or two athletes that that
uh where you look at the distribution of
muscle fibers and one would have let's
say he you said oh you have 70 type 2
fibers and 30 type 1 fibers
but then you find another one as well
you take Usain Bolt and you would say
that okay probably my high but let's use
the same number so 70 type 2 5 30 type 1
5 is
but if you just give a visual if you
just look them initially one would have
like huge thighs another one would have
a small one so you could we could have
the same amount the distribution between
type 1 and type 2 would be the same but
it's just that the other guy has so much
more right fibers in total that you do
understand immediately that right and
obviously a biopsy doesn't tell you that
story exactly and the same thing back to
Power them power I'm asking exactly
about maximizes that maximizing steady
state you will probably not be able to
hold for many hours but uh what you
would be but what you would see there is
a huge range there as well some people
will be able to hold the maximum at the
steady state maybe for 30 minutes before
they start to fatigue others can hold it
for 70 80 maybe 90 minutes before they
before they fatigue and we really don't
know exactly why this is still something
that we are studying uh some people are
saying that it's uh it's in it has to do
with the neurons that are starting to
fatigue others are saying that no that's
it it is due to glycogen availability
running out of glycogen and then the
problem is also that you can't
necessarily because there's also where
we say that well you can store
approximately five six hundred grams of
carbs in your body or glycogen in your
body but that doesn't necessarily tell
you that you can tap into all those five
600 grams of carbs maybe some people
will only be able to tap into 300 of
those before the body will start the
signal and say that okay something
really bad is starting to happen here
now so we're gonna shut you down and
you're not able to override it while
other app is as you train for this you
you learn to tap more and more into
those resources we really don't know
exactly what is and that's why if you
try to explain things only from a
physiological perspective and the
training that you're building up becomes
very physiologically oriented you might
actually lose out on some more very
practical approaches like just saying
okay but okay if we don't understand
physiology
100 there are still black holes there
are gaps to be filled how can we then
understand it for more more practical
practical perspective well go out Target
this speed go for that long and we see
basically where you bumped or you go by
power go out you ride that power until
you see that you see that you maybe not
bound better say that you are not able
to to maintain that power anymore and
you start to get a very good picture of
of also capacity because capacity is
more how much you can do at a certain
intensity over time not only
a power number because that's also the
the let's say the problem with when you
when you say when you when you try to
say something about FTP critical power
um maximum relative steady state and so
on is that you're just telling somebody
that okay my maximum like the steady
state is or my FTP or whatever term you
want to use my anaerobic threshold is
300 watts but again if you have two
riders with the same FTP
one might be quite Superior over the
other ones because basically if you had
now looked at okay how long can you
write this one guy can ride this for for
60 Minutes on another one 30 minutes the
guy that can ride this for 60 minutes
obviously if it's a competition lasting
for 30 minutes he will be able to tap
into something that the guy that only
were able to ride for it for 30 minutes
were not able to tap into so that's why
I think that practical coaches that has
often are more practical or let's say a
physics perspective that I like to have
myself to the approach and just saying
okay if you think of that there's an
input there's an output and in in
between there there is physiology this
this gray box that we do we have a lot
of understanding inside but there's also
a lot of things we don't understand but
you just said okay what this is the
input this is output and you measure it
try to measure things in a very
practical way is very often easier to
get much more specific answers and
understand demand understand limitations
and then you rather use this gray box of
physiology to try to understand how can
we do things smarter but that's where
the evolution right uh is yeah right
right right so to kind of telescope out
a little bit in the broadest sense of
the word how do you think about
intensity allocation for the endurance
athlete like how much of this you know
you're going to get irritated at me but
like if we're just going to use Zone
phraseology like how much is Zone one
how much is zone two how much is
threshold interval Tempo work like how
do you think about that like broadly and
and generally not with respect to a
specific athlete
uh again I think I have a much more like
demand approach to the necessarily Zone
approach it and I think like Gustav and
Christian also said is that in the
training leading into the competition we
of course we we have a plan for okay
this is what we think we need to do or
this is a good good let's say
um plan
but as we train we see that necessarily
that one athlete doesn't respond or
Christian or Gustav doesn't respond
exactly as we've done and then with this
this is where we need to make a make the
adjustments
um
the uh I think where to go with this
because it's a very complicated uh it's
not easy to answer this because I'm much
more demand I'm much more demand driven
and I instruments for me is a way of
doing accounting towards the goal
instead of you just say okay this is a
plan we want to win this competition so
we make a plan for this I guess where my
head is coming from is thinking about
like there's been a lot of press about
like how did kipchogee you know run as
fast as he did recently uh and Killian
jornay publishing his training diary so
you could see exactly you know what he's
done over the last year and and
extracting general principles from that
it paints this picture of how important
like very low intensity work is like how
much is actually being done in zone one
you know would blow people's minds and
defies that argument that
That's Just Junk miles right and also
opens up the door to a conversation
around
um an athlete's perception of intensity
and workouts versus what they're
actually doing so if you take Christian
for example I know that he has this you
know immense capacity to dig very deep
he you know knows how to really probe
that anaerobic engine that he has and
you realize early on in working with him
that on the easy days he was going much
harder than he was meant to and not even
realizing it because he has you know
that capacity to you know be in what
most people would feel to be like the
red zone is that fair does that is that
an accurate okay that's that I think
that's a very good way to put it because
also again back to specificity again you
have a Target
in the training and this is your number
one priority so if you're going to raise
Kona at uh average power of uh 300 watts
for
four hours and 10 minutes
um and that's what's going to bridge you
also or set you up for a really good run
that means that that kind of work
training four hours and 10 minutes or
sometimes a little bit longer low
intensity a little bit shorter a little
bit high intensity but in general around
uh 300 watts then for four hours and 10
minutes
that is your number one goal to improve
in your training and when you when you I
want to improve this in training again
I'm a big believer of specificity under
the body is extremely smart and and
adapts to to to to the things that we we
prepare for
but that means also that if you now have
workers around there on the one side we
know that uh
uh
athletes uh uh that trains Mobile in for
example if you Strava published a study
I think or an article in 2011 12 I don't
I don't remember when but basically what
I took they took all marathoners that
had run a specific marathon and they
basically published the data behind
those that had been running our sub 230
between 233 and so on and also across
genders
and one of the things that you see there
is maybe the the single best predictor
of performance in that context was
volume you just saw that the faster
people running the more volume they had
put in the problem with volume is that
when you put in a lot of volume and you
say okay well maybe if you just put in
even more volume then it must be even
better
if you now don't take into account that
doing that volume also has a demand
basically again uh first of all
thermodynamics that's that that speed
that power that you're doing over those
hours that has a demand so it has to
come from calories
uh you also need to start the feed
accordingly to be able to uphold this
otherwise you're going to run yourself
into the ground at some point
and that means that it how how the
intensity has to be dictated is it or
again have to think about consequences
okay so if this is what I really want to
be good at
if I'm writing a if I'm when you have a
low intensity session or let's say an
easy session where you're just writing
you have to evaluate okay how does this
session now in will that impact that key
session that I have tomorrow
this is also just just something they
can add is that a lot of people talk
about quality sessions
for me uh everything should be a quality
session what is a low intensity medium
it tends to high intensity because we we
must separate quality from intensity
because intensity just tells you where
you are the scale quality is about how
do you execute that specific session and
if you're gonna execute that low
intensity just a junk Mass that's going
to be a lower quality but can also make
it high quality if you have a clear
purpose with it and you know why you put
it in there but it means also that if
you have now you know that have a key
session tomorrow or day after and you
are doing an easy ride today but you're
starting to feel quite fatigued because
you're riding a little bit higher power
because you can you just feel I'm I'm I
feel good today this is really nice I
have good speed there's a Strava segment
whatever that is that you you get a
little bit too hard on the on the pedals
or on the on the Run swim whatever on
that session
that might actually hamper or limit
development that you're gonna have on
the key session in one or two days and
this is why I I think it's much more
important to to to to have those key
sessions and let the other sessions you
learn from the other session and how
they basically Bridge into increased
performance on that key session because
the reason why you have also all the
other sessions around there is because
you believe that having that low
intensity sessions those high intensity
sessions will eventually make you also
better on that key session right and if
you're now starting to use those low
intensity sessions and those high intest
intensity sessions are something where
you you're going to do personal best on
the law intensity sessions you're going
to do personal best on the high
intensity sessions you're real you you
actually setting yourself up for failure
sure and not being able to let's say
personal best on that key session yeah
you're aiming for yeah this this is
unfortunately a place where you don't
have the answer up up front you actually
have to go back and reflect over what
did I do how did I execute this and then
gradually learn and as you learn you
become a smart athlete you become a
better Coach understanding how all these
things comes to better but of course at
some point also you want to see how can
we push this one more step yeah yeah
it's a it's a different definition of
discipline we tend to think of
discipline as the wherewithal to like do
the hard thing you know when when it's
demanded upon us but the true discipline
is being able to hold back and always
bringing the appropriate amount of
intentionality to everything that we're
doing right whether it's to go hard or
to you know check yourself like because
there's that Strava you know segment
coming up and you could be a workout
hero and a race day Zero if you're not
careful like I feel like Strava just
[ __ ] with people's heads and and
probably derails more training programs
than anything that's ever been created
by humankind and back to that also do
lactate for me like that is is is
actually the third layer
for me the first layer is velocity in
the end power doesn't matter power
really doesn't matter either because in
the end you're gonna race in Kona and if
you're producing 500 watts for four
hours and 10 minutes but you are racing
at an average speed of 35 minutes at 35
kilometer power that there obviously is
something wrong yes super nice power
numbers and all this kind of things but
in the end it's not power you're gonna
make you win it's the velocity that's
gonna make you win so that means that
for me the first layer is always
velocity understanding okay what what
the speeds are what are the time you're
going to give because the distance is
absolute
and the only thing that you can make
then do or that you can do than to
bridge down the me I'll say the time
that you're going to take you to raise
the distance is that you need to be able
to increase the velocity power is the
second layer where you can start to
understand now for example by
biomechanical uh
where you can optimize for example
biomechanical because you can you can
still produce a lot of power but if you
are moving more sideways than forward
yeah obviously there is something really
poor with your let's say you're you're a
physician on the bike isn't translating
into velocity like you're it's just
watch for what sake exactly and the same
thing that that's also by the third
layer comes in because now when you're
starting to use lactate and these kind
of things that allows you also to
understand necessarily how efficient are
you producing that power because we also
have to remember that with all the
technology that we have available today
it's still outputted as normally as a
one Hertz metric or let's say like a one
second output but when you pedal around
for example in a circle obviously your
power is not going to be the same
exactly the same power all the way
around that Circle it's going to change
throughout that Circle for example which
we call intracyclic variations and the
same thing as is in swimming also when
you're swimming for example forward you
you might be very powerful and you are
able to accelerate yourself up to very
high instantaneous speed but because you
produce a lot of drag you also Dex rate
very heavily which is not very efficient
you're wasting a lot of energy and being
able to to to work and understand is how
can I actually expand the least possible
energy moving at the same speed forward
is a huge benefit and where lactate
comes in is that now you basically have
moved yourself to the third layer and
that is understanding more the
metabolism part in the body how do you
actually where does energy come from and
with this all these tools instead of
that you have like a starting point
saying okay we're going to win in corner
and you just make a plan and then you
shop in Conan you look at okay how did
this go all these tools allows us
basically to do let's say a form of
accounting as we move and understand
before race day how things are starting
to change how do we adapt how do we
respond to the different stimulus and
allows us to basically make Corrections
before the big day and that's obviously
what we want to do because one plan a
plan is a plan but it's also nothing
more than a plan right so when you're
pricking these guys with needles for
lactate ratings like you know several
times a day during the course of you
know a couple workouts what are you
looking for like what is the data that
is instructive and how you're gauging
the training and approach
so one of the very complicated things
with lactate is that uh it's influenced
by a lot of different factors we touched
upon plasma or let's say also hydration
so how much blood do you have in your
body because the muscles is where
basically the lack that is produced and
is then released out into the
bloodstream
and if you know for example have a
smaller less blood volume that means
that the muscle will still continue to
produce the same amount of lactate
generally speaking
but it also means that if you have a
lower blood volume that means that for
the same intensity now you get a higher
lactic concentration in the blood
if you drink a lot
you're well hydrated you're going to
maybe heat acclimatization the opposite
is going to happen now and if you know
just look at the raw numbers there and
you just compare them from let's say
from week to week or something like this
you will start to make what I would call
like false false positive adjustments in
the program so it lactate is extremely
complicated because you need to
understand it in the bigger picture and
I guess this is also what Gustav also
tried to pinpoint a little bit and also
what we do know is that like that
actually is a fuel it's a super fuel for
the body that the body actually uses
it's it's uh yeah the body actually
prefers to burn like that if it can do
but also we know that metabolism to burn
anything you need oxygen so your VO2 max
will also affect your lactic
concentration and typically as you
specialize for example for an Ironman
distance what will happen is that your
VO2 maximum naturally come down like to
use a very simple example if you get
diarrhea or you are getting sick or
something like this you lose completely
appetite and then you start to eat again
after one week you will feel fill in
your stomach very very early on the
stomach basically is very plastic it
basically pulls together but as you
start to eat more you're getting your
appetite back and so on your your
stomach starts to stretch again same
thing is probably also what is happening
with the heart at least what we have
measured indirectly is because it costs
a lot of energy to have a big stroke
volume the stroke volume will start to
come probably down as you're starting to
specialize for for environment much
faster than we have thought ever before
we don't know yet but this is the
research we are working on so
um now when your VO2 max comes down that
will also now suddenly start to affect
how your body is using the different
substrate or how let's say how the
different substrates is represented in
the blood as lactate and this makes it
very complicated and you have to use uh
us quite a lot of common sense but also
from previous understanding to
understand okay are we where we want to
be or I mean not where we want to be
what is really affecting it for example
if it's hot outside for example much
hotter than it other days the problem is
one of the critical functions for the
body then is to prioritize cooling so
more of the blood in the body will be
redirected from the core towards out the
skin to transport heat from the core
towards the skin and then basically so
you can basically get rid of the
transfer the heat to the to the
surroundings
but also when this is happening that
means also there is a lead blood less
blood going into the muscles and less
blood into the muscles means less oxygen
into the muscles less oxygen into the
muscles means basically that now if
you're going to do the same continue at
the same velocity the body needs to
start to draw more of the local energy
stores the other glycogen carbohydrates
which again will turn out in a higher
lactic concentration so there are so
many things that basically affects
lactate concentration in your blood that
if you're in a very stable environment
and often also the problem with research
is that we are we are trying it's so the
more we do in the field also the more
you understand that even when you go
into a laboratory and you do this kind
of testing that a lot of the testing is
not in Vivo it's actually a form of in
vitro because it's so far out of context
that yes you have to know exactly why we
will continue to use lab lab testing a
lot but you really have to understand
what you re what you are what kind of
information you are getting in the lab
and how you can't or can't transfer that
knowledge to the field again right so on
a practical level
for example like testing Christian or
Gustav out in the field uh you know what
what kind of principles did you extract
from like okay you're in Kona and you're
getting ready for the race and you're
out there and they're getting pricked
and oh it's hot out and like how does
that inform tweaks in the training like
oh we saw something interesting here
with the lactate that we didn't know
beforehand and now we're going to do
this instead of that
so to give a practical example the
typically the closer we get to the race
the more
requirements or demand oriented we we
become because at that time adapting or
ensuring maximum adaptation to what
you're going to do is the most important
thing physiology more has to just come
along but of course you hopefully you
have set up your physiology to be able
to come along the closer you get into
into the race so when now when we are
out in the field and we are doing the uh
testing and let's say I do the lactate
testing on the boys of course and now I
know the context because we have the
core sensors on the body we have the
Moxi sensors on uh as well which where
we can see uh what is the core
temperature how much is it changing is
it changing more than yesterday for
example and if I see for example now the
core temperature is coming up higher
than for example yesterday that would
then I would also at the same power
output I would normally also expect that
Aida delighted is starting to come up a
little bit higher but also it might
start to become unstable too so
it's it and I wouldn't never also do a
decision only based on lactate it would
be based on the other information that I
have available it's only that
information is only as valuable as how
it relates to core body temperature and
10 other data points right exactly yeah
yeah it's just where it gets we all want
to be reductive about this but like the
more you the more you know the more
complicated it is which puts you in a
compromising situation of trying to
explain this to other people like it's
it's very difficult
um the core body temperature piece
though is so interesting I feel like
this is you know a whole new frontier
um that you know is only just beginning
to be understood I had a guy on the
podcast many years ago I was a professor
of biology at Stanford Craig Heller
who'd done a lot of studies on this at
Stanford and had developed like a
cooling glove and realized like he could
get 40 percent boost in performance off
like a pull-up test from his students
when he could maintain a cooler core
body temperature and in a place like
Kona or any endurance event where the
body naturally overheats you tip over
into a Zone from which you cannot return
and it's disastrous right so to the
extent that you can understand Core Body
tap and figure out a way to you know as
Gustav and Christian were putting it
earlier
um tolerate you know an increase in core
body temperature or maintain a lower
core body temperature that is a massive
key to gigantic performance gains I
would think and in terms of energy
expenditure from your perspective it's a
function of looking at okay you know you
were saying earlier like you know that
the law of like you know no energy is
wasted like energy and energy out well
that energy in is that going towards
velocity or is that going towards you
know cooling your body temperature and
figuring out how to you know kind of
get that equation you know the best that
it can possibly be
it's actually
um one of the things that really
triggered me when it came to heat and I
were actually uh
[Music]
green text sensor that the core sensor
that the white thing that they're
wearing on the belts
is that
we normally say that the body or if you
look at your computer by computer you'll
see that normally that when you do a
certain amount amount of work you get
out of a calorie amount and you think
okay how can this know this and that is
of course that we know that it's a very
tight correlation between power
and calorimetry and that's because some
of the tests that had been done in the
past says that there is a rather fixed
ratio between
mechanical Power and thermal power the
and thermal power is what we we couldn't
measure in the past
so when you just do this work now they
normally we said that the body is 25
efficient in reality it's less than 20
it depends a little bit what kind of
modality what kind of sport you are
doing but normally you would say 20 21
efficiency that that is what it is but
this boils down to how you measure it
also a little bit that's why maybe we
have seen higher numbers also in the
past because it it depends a little bit
on how we measure and traditionally how
this was mentioned in in the past and uh
also today is that you you use indirect
calorimetry you're using a mask or to to
measure uh your oxygen uptake again what
we have done and where this has been
important for us is to advances into the
field and we are working with a Canadian
company to
be able to get rid of all types of wires
and so on so that is really wants to use
it feels comfortable to use it and at
the same time you can feed that data
straight into our Buy computer source or
or or sports watches so that we can
start to look at for example mechanical
Power
and the calorimetry because in between
the difference between those two or
let's say the missing piece there if you
calculate just calorimetric power into
mechanic or into Power like say pure
power you'll see there's a huge
component missing and that will you see
there's approximately eighty percent so
then where does this 80 go most of it
heat
the problem with that obviously is that
when you know your muscles are doing
work on the bike you're taking calories
and calories will ultimately be the
ceiling to your performance you can't
get more energy than what you have
trained your body to deliver at any
given time
so in the same way as in Formula One For
example they're really trying to improve
the efficiency of the cars and today
they're talking about maybe more than 50
efficiency of the combustion engines
it's not because the combustion engine
in itself is capable of out or outside
turning fuel directly into
50 into pure mechanical Power is because
they actually are recycling the heat
that the engine is is so the efficiency
of the engine is probably around 20 25
as well as it's but the rest of it is
actually just taking the heat that the
engine is producing and they are able to
recycle also a big part of that back
into mechanical into mechanical Power
and of course in the body the what
happens is that when you're exercising
and we know that now certainly for every
calorie that you are burning
twenty percent of that goes into
velocity or power
and eighty percent of that goes into
heat so where does the heat go obviously
now there we have a huge thermal
capacity so we can store a lot of that
heat but that will at some point become
a problem because we will start overheat
and the body will will try to get rid of
as much as possible of the heat but then
one of the ways to do this is exactly
that the body starts to prioritize
bringing blood instead into the muscles
out towards the skin and getting rid of
it so this is of course where I we we
need to we need to understand how how
does this how does this work and where
we had a very experimental approach to
it and we did everything from rectal
probes to rectal pills to to basically
okay which is
isn't not very invasive because that is
have gone become so used to it that it's
uh that it's uh okay it is it's okay
just do it but on the other side it's a
very expensive method to approach or to
use and here now what I knew that there
was a lot of patches on the market that
of course said yeah we can measure the
quarter temperature or this kind of
thing but they do the same way as if you
have a if your kid is sick or something
like this and you take the
front you scan the frontal lobe with the
thermometers it will give you a call
give you a core temperature or
temperature of your body but the thing
is that it doesn't measure it it just
takes the skin temperature it's not it's
not a true accurate measurement no it
just takes your skin temperature and
applies a constant what really intrigued
me with the sensor that core produced
was that uh or Green Tech produced was
that it's basically there are two
sensors in there and that is the one
that measures the skin temperature but
there also is a thermal power meter in
it
so if you had made this one in metal and
you put your cooking stove to two
kilowatts and you put it on there this
won't be able to measure that okay
there's two kilowatts output now
that's crazy and now suddenly we can
have this on the body and that's why
there are picture out of course with
Crystal it literally tells you how much
energy your body is producing and
directly the temperature piece yes
exactly wow so this is now uh uh let's
say a Bluetooth to the Garmin yeah no
actually a t plus but also Bluetooth
yeah straight into the Garment so you
can have it there so you actually have
both no mechanical Power and thermal
power
looking at it that's freaking crazy so
what we also then want to optimize is
basically how can we take those calories
those those limited calories that we
actually can turn into work per minute
per second per minute per hour how can
we optimize that because again calories
are the limit how can we now increase
the ratio between the Soma part and the
mechanical part from an evolutionary
perspective that ratio sounds crazy yeah
that only 20 goes into actual you know
what would you call it like energy
output 80 percent to heat management it
doesn't seem right like how do they how
did how did humans survive yeah you know
it's so inefficient yeah but probably
that was also one of the keys when you
didn't have like very I'm just speckling
because this is some this of course is a
topic I didn't research very much but
because it doesn't affect the
performance of the boys uh too much or
knowing this but I one could maybe
speculate that we didn't have proper
clothing or these kind of things and and
then the body needed to be able to keep
yourself warm so a lot of the calories
had to go into heating your body and
making sure that your body stays at a
very delicate temperature and then the
rest is worse yeah and we didn't need to
be able to be more uh uh efficient
because also actually if you look at it
more from an evolutionistic perspective
one of the things that I I was really
fascinated doing research into Tokyo
Olympics where we knew that it was very
hot instead of going by necessarily that
okay we need a cooling vest we need air
conditioners and all this kind of things
I knew that well there are tribes there
are people native people around in the
world they go out in the daytime and
they hunt down animals in the scorching
Sun how are they able to survive this
and what I found there is that of course
they've been written books about this as
well and that is that you basically see
that humans are probably one of the most
Superior species in exactly also heat
management which allows us basically to
track down and hunt animals that are
much faster than us but we do have the
endurance because we're able to
dissipate the Heat and we can just go on
and go on and go on those animals can't
dissipate heat they ultimately Keel over
and the human wins the persistent hunt
exactly right so that that is the
evolutionary Advantage right there
probably just explained it yeah it's
amazing I come from a swimming
background and you know obviously when
you're in the pool even if the water is
is somewhat warm it's much cooler than
your core body temperature right so your
body is expending a lot of energy just
to maintain uh core temperature which is
why I think swimming is so exhausting
but also why you can spend a lot of time
in the pool like you can keep swimming
for extended periods of time because
you're not going to overheat in the way
that you would running but ultimately
you get I find you get more tired like
you know the sleep is deeper and you
walk around like a zombie you're
overdoing it in the pool the the
interesting thing is that exactly for
the same reason that you say that is
that because here the the water is
taking so much energy from your body
yeah because you need the body needs to
ramp up the heat production if you
measure gross efficiency in in in
cycling you'll see that it's typical it
sits for an elite around 20 20 21
for for uh subleases actually it's a
little bit lower uh when I started work
with Christian we saw that his
biochemical efficiency or I I
distinguish between biochemical and
biomechanical cross efficiency is for me
like where you measure from Calamity to
Velocity while you can separate it into
biomechanical but just looking at
mechanical Power to Velocity and on the
other side for mechanical Power power to
Calamity and that's where you get your
biochemical efficiency and this is where
this is where as a Christian when I met
him he had a biochemical efficiency of
around 17 now it sits around 19 20 19 20
but one thing that we see that that's
for cycling
in swimming is between five to ten
percent so there you see that basically
only five to ten percent of the calories
that you're inputting are getting out in
terms of velocity and the rest is pure
heat because the body needs to use a lot
more energy
to basically make sure that you don't
get the go into hypothermia right yeah
wow that's wild how does how does heart
rate variability play into this as a
valid data point
uh I not so much I collect it's
interesting because I I'm saying that
sorry to interrupt but because we're all
you know keen on the wearables and I've
got the whoop and the or all that kind
of stuff like suddenly there's a
discourse you know around heart rate
variability that didn't even exist like
two years ago unless you know somebody
had you know your kind of background it
for for me Hardware heart rate
variability is like a very isolated or
small metric of course on one side we
say that it is irrepresentative to the
to the to the nervous system or it gives
a representation of the nervous system
but uh
I do think that so HIV obviously is a
result of something you can see that of
course that it becomes more uh
um that your heart rate more like beats
like very more much more like a clock
which is not too good you wanted to
dance around a little bit but on the
other side you don't want to dance Too
Much around either which is not too good
so there's like a delicate balance in
between there but
uh I was a predictor of Readiness and
your you know capacity to endure strain
on that particular day the in the
interesting thing is that if you had
measure they're so small adjustments you
can do and it will start to affect HRV
so for example because we collect so
much data we can start to look at it
over time not only not only just there
the spot picture but basically from also
how EV every workout even affects it and
both in the workout but also between the
workouts and so and one of the things
that we do I see when I've been looking
at the data
is that if you do for example you can go
into a workout you feel like you're not
good at all you look at the HIV and says
okay that you see that maybe here there
are some indicators also indicating that
but just simple breathing exercises can
sometimes make a difference to your HRV
that's for one uh your perception but
also when you do a warm-up if you do a
good like a controlled good warm-up
suddenly also the HIV can be completely
different also afterwards so letting the
HRV that's why I'm very afraid of
letting the HRV dictate what you should
do because it's then you are done
instead of trying to do something with
it you're just letting the past dictate
a little bit what's going to happen so
for me HIV this is an interesting metric
but it's not a metric that I would guy
use to basically determine something
it's more something I would say that if
an athlete feels fatigue we also said
okay let's try to do something that we
know normally seems to get you into a
state where you actually start to feel
ready again
I would rather go by the feeling of the
athlete
than going by HRV HIV would not even be
the second metric I would look at okay
first the feeling was actually done the
HIV it's comes fairly long down the road
before I would yeah that's super
interesting yeah you know I have a habit
of not like checking the the data in the
morning because I don't want it to be a
predictor of what I'm supposed to do
which is sort of weird because it's kind
that's kind of what it's meant to do but
if I feel a little off and I know I've
got a bunch of stuff I got to do you
know on that day I don't want to look at
it and have it tell me like I shouldn't
do those things or that you know that
so there's a weird mental thing I think
that happens with that as well for me uh
if you had an electrical car
the problem with the human body is that
we don't have like any Gorges on our way
we can just look at our hand and it
basically says okay you are recharged
this much for example
and also the a lot of the metrics that
we have today they are not really uh uh
they are like very isolated very
isolated metrics and the problem uh with
that is that it's like if you if you
have electrical car you drive during the
day and you and and in reality you're
using 20 battery you come back home you
put it to charging and you're charging
the next day you expect it to be 100
again you go to work again spending
another 20 back home put into charging
again every day you do this but
let's say that there was something wrong
and actually the input to your car was
only 10 during that night that means
that after a certain amount of days your
car will actually run out of
electricity
for use when you're sitting there
because you don't have a let's say in
this car you don't have the indicators
now in the same way that we don't have
the screen together you're sitting there
wondering what on Earth did go wrong
with my car today
obviously there you can bring it to to
the workshop and they will immediately
say oh your empty battery unfortunately
that's much more complicated with the
body you can't basically just say that
okay now now I'm over trained or like
this or something like this it's such
it's so much more difficult to predict
the performance or predict whether over
training all the things occur for me
that one of the best the best recovery
predictors is more that you have to look
at things from a day-to-day basis so for
example if you see that for example your
general mood and every like these kind
of things are in general they are yes
they will fracture a little bit but you
basically are you see that you you look
forward to get out in the exercise or
exercising this kind of thing or
especially when you come back you
basically see that for example the power
you're outputting the speed that you're
outputting compared to your feeling in
the body compared to your heart rate and
other things you basically see that it
looks good and maybe even improving in
improving but it also resembles the
feeling that you have in your body that
is for me the single best predictor of
that you are in a place where you're
recovering sufficiently yeah kind of
thing so rather looking at the trends
and how you how you you you progress
according to plan and these kind of
things that is for me the single best
predictor compared to any other metric
that are on available on the market
we're running out of time I know you
guys got another appointment you gotta
go I feel like we're an hour and a half
into what could be a five hour
conversation because I've barely even
started with all the things that I want
to know about from you but before I let
you go I do want to uh dive a little bit
more in detail into the world of
recovery obviously
an athlete's ability to recover in
between training sessions is you know
perhaps the most important thing that's
gonna you know predict success to the
extent that you can
um
enhance recovery and compress the amount
of time required for an athlete to
bounce back in between those training
sessions that's going to translate into
performance gains uh realize sooner
rather than later so how do you think
about recovery what are the pillars of
recovery that you think are important
and what are some things that perhaps a
lot of athletes out there spend a lot of
time thinking about uh that maybe are
less important listening to the body I
think is probably very underrated and
learning to listen to your body is
because the data guy is so interesting
yeah but data guys telling me to listen
to my body but that's because there are
two extremely important data stream one
is the objective qualitative no
quantitative data stream on the other
side you have the uh the quality data
stream basically meaning uh from and
that's also that's something that you
have to invest in and you have to train
and you can of course use the you will
gain strength and you will be able to
advance faster connecting it with the
the the
objective or quantitative data stream
but learning to listen to your body and
also having patience knowing that okay
if I rush it today yes I have a
competition coming up in two weeks but
if you rush it on a hard session today
that might actually be more
fatal damaging yeah to to the end result
then actually just saying that okay
today I'm a little bit unsecure I go out
I go easy a little bit I feel how my
body responds if it's not there I'm just
gonna do a little bit go back and make
sure that I'm ready for the next session
again because one single session
will not make a big difference to the
increase in your performance but it can
be enough to basically tip the whole
result off in two weeks time if you
really if you start to rush it right I
think that decision has a lot to do with
where The Athlete's head is at and how
confident or unconfident they are about
the upcoming event that's why I think
also it's important to have somebody to
discuss the training with also because
they can maybe be the one that are able
to bring that perspective into your life
as well
but among those pillars I suspect you
know sleep is at the top of uh you know
the food chain there yes sleep nutrition
obviously is extremely important we
don't believe very much in
supplementation or things like I'm again
I'm very demand oriented meaning that if
you take a supplement it should be
because you have the doctor or somebody
have identified that there you are
lacking something here and you will try
to compensate it by for example go to
altitude use iron supplementation if you
live in the nordics you're alone in
vitamin D okay try to supplement with
vitamin D and C if it make a change but
we don't use we actually don't use
supplements Beyond actually what you eat
as a normal food and if you eat nice
varied food healthy foods uh not
obsessing of it because calories again
is very important to get in so if you're
only eating salads and all these kind of
things obviously you're gonna have to
eat a table of salad too yeah maybe even
be close so again calories is super
important sleep is super important but
also being in a place where you are able
to recover mentally to is very important
and I think that in the end it boils
down to choices if you really want to
excel you prioritize it
otherwise you're cheating yourself
um yeah
uh we talked about uh aerodynamics with
with the lads earlier if you guys want
to hear about that just listen to that
conversation that was a whole other
Rabbit Hole I wanted to dive down with
you but I do have to let you go
um
I appreciate how open and transparent
you've been with all the modalities and
techniques that you're playing around
with like you're very open to discussing
these things and not worried about other
coaches figuring out what your recipe is
but I'm sure you've got a whole other
batch of stuff that you're up to that
that is under you know lock and key and
is T is top secret but what would be
like what's the next
like if you had to design the optimal
study to solve whatever dilemma is
playing out in your mind about how to
unlock Ultimate Human Performance like
what would that look like like what are
you thinking about now where is your you
know training mindset evolving towards
so this is where probably I would have
to apply the same thing that I like to
apply to my athletes and that is sharing
something sharing your competitive
Advantage but it boils of course a
little bit down to the doubly labeled
water and maximum sustainable energy
expenditure because on the one side we
see that there is a very tight
correlation between performance and
volume volume is a very gross gross
estimate of what you're doing doesn't
say something about the work obviously
because there's a lack of intensity you
can do 20 officer training at 100 once
you can go 20 hours of trading at 200
watts and that has at least a double
amount of energy expended
uh so maybe even or better predictor of
performance is expected to understand
rather from a telemetric perspective how
much or from a from a distance power
whatever kilojoules uh distance
perspective but maximum sustainable
energy expenditure understanding
actually how we can even Advance this
because there are this is something that
Humanity have tried to understand for
for decades and that is what are the
limits to Performance we have set view
to Max and threshold and all these kind
of things but in reality it's like
exactly like you also pinpoint yeah but
you see some people that can do this for
30 minutes you see some can do it for
two hours yes exactly that's because we
are all very often when we look at
performance we only quantify them as
power metrics and not capacity metrics
and that is also the thing here is that
I think that maybe one of the single
best predictors of performance is
maximum sustainable energy expenditure
and we in literature that and research
have been done on Tour de France writers
uh during two uh yeah during two defense
Giroud Italia Ultra Runners and so on
they basically see that there's a there
seems to be a limitation around 2.5
times the resting metabolic rate
we know from the studies we have done
that we are at a much higher number and
so then you can ask okay so what
basically if you have one hour to train
per week and that comes back again we
can if you plot you on your performance
you're going to run Boston Marathon or
whatever
most likely your performance will be
accordingly if you have a 20 hours of
training your performance will be much
better most likely and then the question
is well where's the limit where is The
Limited so if there is a correlation
they're going up and you can get better
and better and better I already know
that these guys uh Gustav and Christian
are putting down a huge amount of work
not yeah work is probably the right word
uh measuring kilojoules kilocalories and
my question now is just how can we
really now start to manipulate the
training and maybe we are on a verge of
starting to put training together in a
different way this is we don't have the
answers we just have to do the research
we have to take the risk of experiment a
little bit but that is actually one of
the things that I'm really starting to
play around with now because if you want
to have a high view to Max let's say
that Gustav or Christian went into an
arm and now with a much higher view to
Max that would on the one side just from
a two-dimensional picture be more ideal
but in order now to excel equally much
at what is the specific demand of the
race that means that you have to be able
to you have to spend much more energy to
both maintain that High View to Max at
the same time be able to to to to do the
specific work that you are looking to do
and that uh it puts higher Demand on
recovery sleep it's how you put together
the training and everything so that is
for me now invite when we if we when we
sit down and talk again that this
perspective might have changed because I
have we have gone even further down
you've explored it more deeply at that
time yeah but that's where I am now
right but but we're nowhere near the
limit right no you know that we know
that and that means that uh we've got
exciting times to come because I know
you guys are hard at work at this and I
can't wait to see you know how this
plays out in the years to come so I
gotta let you go please consider this
part one of a multi-part series come
back because I got a million more
questions for you and uh it's just
fascinating what you're doing I
appreciate the work you're doing and for
taking the time to share with us today I
accept already all right Excellent Man
cool uh I'll let you guys go thank you
for an amazing day all of you guys and
uh best of luck and please if there's
anything I can do for any of you uh
consider me and my team here a resource
thank you so much cheers I'm so honored
yeah yeah truly the honor is all mine my
friend cheers peace
thank you
[Music]